You all know how much I love scary mazes and
theme parks, so I just have to talk about
this trailer for Hellfest.
This is gonna be a pretty short video though,
so just roll the intro.
OK, as soon as I saw this scene with the hammer,
I was thinking it would be really cool if
that was used as a weapon somewhere in the
movie.
And sure enough at the end of the trailer
here, there's a quick shot of the stalker
using it as a weapon.
I also thought that the slider being a zombie
head thing was a nice touch and this could
be a metaphor for the point that we're reaching
maximum intensity in this movie.
The friend character has all of this hippie
stuff in her room, so I wonder if there's
going to be a scene where she has a chance
to take out the killer or something, and she
doesn't because she's all anti-violent.
I don't know, just a thought.
I was looking at some of the themed areas,
because I love analysing that stuff in theme
parks.
I mean, I used to do theme park videos when
I was a kid.
So there were two areas that stood out to
me.
The first being this, which maybe like an
evil twist on Alice in Wonderland, with these
Mushrooms and the decaying trees back here,
and then this like a guy standing in a big
zombie head teacup thing.
The announcer is a kind of like a mad hatter
type of character.
Then the other area I thought was interesting
was maybe like a haunted school theme, which
I think is actually pretty unique idea.
You've got a classroom, a gym locker room,
and a hallway.
I like seeing some original themed areas that
aren't just intellectual property based, but
it looks like this movie will feature some
characters who are kind like parodie horror
IPs.
We've got knockoffs of Saw, The Strangers,
Beetlejuice, Predator, The Walking Dead...
and some that are probably not intentional
but I'm gonna mention anyways just for laughs
like Argghus, The Earthshapers and... wait
a minute this one actually looks strikingly
similar.
One of the lines in this trailer gave me an
idea.
Roll that clip.
"The same guy's been following me the entire
night."
I actually like the idea of a theme park hiring
a few character actors to just stalk certain
groups the entire night.
Like if I owned a horror nights type thing,
I'd have maybe 5-10 actors that I tell to
just shadow the same group of kids.
It would be way creepier than any of the mazes.
I know that's not what's going on in Hell
Fest, but I just thought I'd share that idea,
I think it's pretty cool.
Like I said, not a whole lot to talk about
here, so if you're looking for more content
this week, I was in a collab where I play
this creepy camp counselor, so go check this
video out.
Al Dente Creepypasta is coming back with a
new episode next week, so make sure you're
subscribed to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring that deathbell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.